to me entrepreneurship is about creating
change not just creating companies
movies and pop culture just get this all
wrong the idea of a single Eureka moment
is a dangerous lie in a world that's
changing so quickly the biggest risk you
can take is not taking any risk wanna
soar get a mentor
what's up belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn
from one of the best Mark Zuckerberg and
some of his best life-changing advice
mentor me mark also if you want to know
what Mark and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below the biggest risk
you can take is not taking any risk
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one make mistakes so many things go
wrong when you're starting a company and
often I think people ask you know what
mistakes should you avoid making and you
know my answer that question is don't
even bother trying to avoid mistakes
because you're gonna make tons of
mistakes right and the the important
thing is actually learning quickly from
whatever mistakes you make and not
giving up right and I mean there are
things every single year of Facebook's
existence that could have killed us or
made it so that it just seemed like
moving forward and making a lot of
progress just seemed intractable but you
just kind of bounce back and you learn
and nothing is impossible you just have
to kind of keep running through the
walls we'll over to create change to me
entrepreneurship is about creating
change not just creating companies and
you know the most effective
entrepreneurs that who I've met it care
deeply about some mission and some
change that they're trying to create and
often they don't even start because
they're trying to create a company right
and you know that's how I think about
you know my connection to to all of us
here is when I was getting started I am
and I want it I care deeply about giving
everyone a voice right and giving people
the tools to share everything that they
cared about and bringing a community
together and it started small and in one
university and I didn't think it was
gonna be a company at the time as a
matter of fact I was pretty convinced
that at some point someone would build
something like this for the world but
you know I thought that that would be
some other company that you know already
had thousands of engineers and was used
to building stuff for hundreds of
millions of people around the world and
you know what ended up happening was you
know that no one built it right so we
just kind of kept on going right I mean
people said it each step along the way
you know what you're doing all right
maybe college students like it but no
one else is gonna like it and you know
there's not gonna be any money in doing
this so all right so you only really do
it if you care all right if you're
passionate about doing it and then it
started growing and people said it would
be a fad and it would never be a good
business but you know you keep going
because you care
not because you're trying to create a
business and you know then there's the
shift in mobile where people thought
that you know it wouldn't be a
sustainable business and you know each
of these things you the entrepreneurs so
I think build things that last for a
long time keep going because they care
fundamentally about the change that
they're trying to create in the world
and they're not in it just to build a
company rule number three just get
started
ideas don't come out fully formed they
only become clear as you work on them
you just have to get started if I had to
know everything about connecting people
before I got started I never would have
built Facebook movies and pop culture
just get this all wrong
the idea of a single Eureka moment is a
dangerous lie it makes us feel
inadequate because we feel like we
haven't had ours yet and it prevents
people with seeds of good ideas from
ever getting started in the first place
rule number four be proud of what you do
if we've given the world a voice look at
what's happened in the last year you've
had elections in the last year's
elections manipulated hate speech that's
gone viral and turned offline it
certainly seems like this mission has
been accomplished in many ways and and
there's a whole new set of problems that
perhaps you guys didn't foresee and now
we're in a very complicated place where
there's not an easy solution yeah
there's these are complex issues that
you can't fix you manage them on an
ongoing basis but look do you think that
the world is better with everyone having
a voice and having the ability to
express their opinion and being able to
connect to who they want I don't think
we're going back to a world where there
were just a handful of gatekeepers who
got to control what ideas get expressed
and even if and even if we could well
I'm trying to make it so we're not I
mean that's why making it so that we're
building these independent governance
mechanisms and things like that are
really important and that's that's work
that I that I really care about but I
think that the world will keep on moving
in this direction people will more
people will keep on getting a voice I
think that that's good
and and and and I think there are
certainly going to be issues that we
need to work through over time but I
think that while we are doing that we
can't lose sight of all of the really
positive things that are that are
happening here as well not just in terms
of communities and people being able to
to connect with with groups that are
really meaningful to them whether it's
around a disease or or a community
around veterans that they wouldn't be
able to connect to otherwise but even if
you just think about the economic impact
of what we're doing you know we serve 80
million small businesses around the
world about half of them have told us
that they're hiring people because of
using our tools and that without
Facebook and the tools that we that we
provide and that they that their
business would be significantly smaller
and they wouldn't be hiring as many
people as they are so you know a study
came out the US economy added about four
and a half million jobs over the last
year if you just look at like what
people are telling us the small
businesses who use our tools we've
directly been able to contribute to
creating many more jobs than that across
the world so I think that this is the
power of giving people a voice giving
small businesses giving communities
giving everyone everywhere the ability
to connect with the people who who they
care about and get their opinion across
and giving every day people the power
that previously only big companies would
have had so that's the world was gonna
go more in that direction and I think by
and large that's a good thing so I'm
really proud of the work that we're
doing on this and we there are big
issues and I'm not trying to to say that
there aren't that we need to work
through but I do think that sometimes
you can you can get the flavor from a
lot of this from from some of the
coverage that that that's all there is
and and I don't think that that's right
either we need to make sure that we
address these these questions these are
really big and important things for the
future of our society in the future of
the internet but we also need to keep
pushing in the direction of empowering
more people because that's good
rule number five take risks in a world
that's changing so quickly the biggest
risk you can take is not taking any risk
and I really think that that's true
right a lot of people I think think that
you know whenever it comes to
whatever you get yourself into a
position where you have to make some
some big shift and direction or do
something you know there are always
people are going to point to the
downside risks of that decision and
locally there may be right right I mean
if for any given decision that you're
gonna make there's upside and downside
but in aggregate if you are stagnant and
you don't make those changes then then I
think you're guaranteed to fail right
and not not catch up so to some degree I
think it's really right that over time
the biggest risk that you can take is to
not take any risks and rule number six
the last 24 a very special bonus clip is
take on big challenges Facebook is a
for-profit company why call it dot org
is this a non-profit is this charity you
know if we were primarily focused on
profits the the most reasonable thing
for us to do would be to really just
focus on the first billion people who
are using our products I mean the world
isn't set up equally and you know the
the first billion people are using
Facebook have way more money than the
rest of the world combined so from a
business perspective it actually doesn't
make a huge amount of sense for us to
put the emphasis in this that we are
right now the reason why we're doing it
is two things one is mission right I
mean we're here to help connect the
world and we take that really seriously
and you know you to some degree you
can't really do that if two-thirds of
the world doesn't even have access to
the Internet so you know we just turned
ten as a company and we just added them
in our next ten years we want to take on
some really big challenges in the world
like helping everyone get online and
that's just an important thing for for
us and I think for a lot of other
internet companies and for flowing this
mission overall now over the long term I
do think it could be good for for our
company as well if you look at it at a
10 20 30 year time horizon because a lot
of these countries and economies will
develop and over time they will be
important now I've got a special bonus
clip for mark that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching under the video
to taking action in your life for
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what big
challenge do you need to take on number
two what are
you most proud of in what you do and
number three what do you just need to
get started on but the students around
me were really important as well right
and both in high school and in college I
mean the people who started Facebook
with me and a lot of people who are
still with me running the company today
are people who I met when I was at
Harvard and some of them were mighty ups
at Harvard right and you know when the
professors were off writing papers these
were the people who actually taught me
and then we hung out and we had like
social bonds and academic bonds and I
just I wouldn't understate the
importance of that and I mean it's very
tied into my whole philosophy and the
product that that I've spent my life
building Facebook because we just
believe that social bonds are critical
and um in one way that I think about the
the value that Facebook is filling in
the world is that you go through school
and at least when I did people just
focused on you know academics like
achievement different areas and one of
the things that no one really ever
taught me was like having friends is
really valuable no I'm not that I didn't
have friends but but like although you
know the movie yes make it seem that
but that first girlfriend this would for
sure I don't think anyone is like it's
not like okay third-grade we're gonna
like
now we're gonna like teach you that like
hanging out with people is a very
important development right and I don't
know I actually think that that is and I
think that's part of the reason why
sometimes people view Facebook as a
waste of time but I actually think it's
this extremely socially valuable utility
and I know that I wouldn't be where I
want where I am today without that
aspect of my life being as developed as
the academic part
if you want to learn the story of Marx
Facebook success check the video there
right next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
I didn't think at all that it was gonna
be a company I remember very
specifically the night that that we
launched the first version I went out to